last week I posted a very important poll
to Twitter the question who is the worst
wife in America
[Music]
there were four options Jill Biden
Meghan Markle Jada Pinkett Smith and
Gisele fetterman the wife of Senator
John Federman now proved to be a close
contest the one clear winner emerged at
the end Jada Pinkett Smith GI Jane as
Chris Rock would call her who has uh
escorted her husband Will Smith through
one public humiliation ritual after
another close behind her was Meghan
Markle assuming her preferred position
by writing someone else's coattails and
then first lady and notorious Elder
abuser Jill Biden with 22 percent
followed finally by Gisele fetterman
with only 14 percent of the vote